This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. As anyone who has ever been to a White Castle restaurant knows, the food is... how do I put this? It's never going to be considered classic five-star food, but you know what you're getting when you go there. Jeremy Brooks has been a die-hard White Castle fan ever since going regularly as a kid with his dad. That's either something you're going to love or you cannot stand.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。正如任何去过白色城堡（White Castle）餐厅的人所知，那里的食物……我该怎么说呢？它永远不会被视为经典的五星级美食，但当你去那里时，你很清楚自己会得到什么。杰里米·布鲁克斯从小就经常和父亲一起去，从此成了白色城堡的铁杆粉丝。这要么是你非常喜欢的东西，要么是你无法忍受的东西。
For starters, the patties are square. That's kind of their thing, with five holes in each patty. And they're small too. Two and a half inch sliders just big enough to fit in the palm of your hand. And since they're steamed on a bed of onions, everything is infused with this very specific onion-esque flavor. Plus you get the steamed buns too, so they're nice and soft, so you can basically just like squish it in your hand and just shove it in your mouth if you want. Like the man said, you either love it or you hate it. I happen to love it and I still do 40 plus years later. If you've never been to a white, though, that's not entirely surprising. They're not exactly easy to come by.
首先，他们的肉饼是方形的。这是他们的特色，每块肉饼上有五个孔。而且它们很小。两英寸半的滑块汉堡（slider）刚好能放在你的手掌心里。因为它们是在洋葱床上蒸熟的，所以每一口都浸透了这种非常独特的洋葱风味。再加上蒸过的面包，口感非常松软，所以如果你愿意，基本上可以直接把它捏在手里塞进嘴里。就像那个人说的，你要么爱它，要么恨它。我恰好很喜欢，而且40多年后的今天依然如此。不过，如果你从来没去过白色城堡，那也不足为奇。它们确实不太容易见到。
That's reporter-producer Mackenzie Martin who first dug into the story for the KCUR studio's podcast, A People's History of Kansas City. But that obscurity is also kind of White Castle's thing. They're only in the US, and your state probably doesn't have any. If it does, even just making it there can sometimes be challenging. Like in the 2004 buddy comedy, Harold and Kumar Go to White Castle.
那是记者兼制作人麦肯齐·马丁，她最初为KCUR工作室的播客《堪萨斯城人民史》挖掘了这个故事。但这种默默无闻也算是白色城堡的特色。它们只在美国有，而且你所在的州可能一家都没有。即使有，有时候想去吃上一顿也很有挑战性。就像2004年的伙伴喜剧《猪头逛大街》（Harold and Kumar Go to White Castle）里那样。
A film in which the entire plot revolves around trying to find a White Castle. What happened to the White Castle? What? There used to be a White Castle right here in this location. Where is it? I hate to be the bear of bad news, guys used to be a White Castle right here in this location. Where is it? I hate to be the bear of bad news, guys, but Bergershack, they bought this location about
这部电影的整个情节都围绕着寻找一家白色城堡展开。白色城堡怎么了？什么？这个地方以前有一家白色城堡。它在哪儿？我不想当那个带来坏消息的人，伙计们，这个地方以前确实有一家白色城堡。它在哪儿？我不想当那个带来坏消息的人，伙计们，但是汉堡小屋（Burgershack）在大概
four years ago. Please tell me there's another White Castle in town. No. White Castles are so scattered that even I, the reporter of this story, have never actually been to one. Where I live in Kansas City, we haven't had a White Castle in decades, which is absolutely crushing to superfan Jeremy Brooks. I drive by the places where I know those locations used to be and I'll look at the building and
四年前买下了这个店面。请告诉我城里还有别的白色城堡。没有了。白色城堡分布得如此稀疏，以至于连我这个报道这个故事的记者，也从来没去过一家。我住在堪萨斯城，我们这里几十年来都没有白色城堡了，这对超级粉丝杰里米·布鲁克斯来说简直是毁灭性的打击。我开车经过那些我知道以前有店面的地方，我会看着那栋建筑，
just let a little client sigh out as I drive on by. And for most people today, that's really all White Castle is. A semi-obscure, guilty pleasure, cultural punchline. Which, okay fine, it kinda is. But White Castle is also so much more than that. Because over a century ago, White Castle invented something that became so important and all-encompassing that today it touches pretty much every person in America. Sometimes several times a day.
然后在我开车经过时轻轻叹口气。对于今天的大多数人来说，白色城堡真的就只是这样。一个半隐秘的、带有负罪感的快乐，一个文化梗。好吧，确实有点像。但白色城堡的意义远不止于此。因为一个多世纪前，白色城堡发明了一些东西，它们变得如此重要且无处不在，以至于今天它几乎触及了美国的每一个人。有时一天好几次。
Something that, in other countries, has almost come to define American culture. White Castle has the strongest claim to have been the first restaurant that is a fast food restaurant. That's Adam Chandler, a journalist and the author of Drive Through Dreams, a book about Americans' love affair with fast food. And Chandler says that before McDonald's, before Burger King, before combination Pizza Hut
在其他国家，这种东西几乎成了美国文化的代名词。白色城堡最有资格声称自己是第一家快餐店。这是亚当·钱德勒，一位记者，也是《得来速之梦》（Drive Through Dreams）的作者，这是一本关于美国人对快餐热恋的书。钱德勒说，在麦当劳之前，在汉堡王之前，在必胜客和塔可钟的组合店之前，就有白色城堡了。
and Taco Bell, there was White Castle. You cannot throw a stone in the air without hitting a fast food restaurant. But what White Castle really did in paving the way for all of its brethren is hard to match. It's hard to understand, it's hard to grasp because it came from virtually nothing. The first chain restaurant in the United States
你随便扔块石头，都能砸中一家快餐店。但白色城堡在为所有同行铺平道路方面所做出的贡献是很难比拟的。这很难理解，很难领会，因为它几乎是从无到有创造出来的。美国的第一家连锁餐厅
popped up in the late 19th century, catering to disembarking passengers along the Atchison to Pika and Santa Fe Railway. But it catered to a fancier clientele and it didn't serve food all that fast. For that, you were stuck with your typical food cards or automats. And crucially, none of these places served anything that we moderns would recognize as a hamburger.
出现在19世纪末，为艾奇逊、托皮卡和圣达菲铁路沿线下车的乘客提供服务。但它迎合的是更高端的客户，而且上菜速度并不快。为此，你只能选择典型的餐车或自动售货机。最关键的是，这些地方都没有提供我们现代人所认知的汉堡包。
Back then, we had kind of a loose confederation of places that served hamburger-like objects. These proto burgers usually involved loosely ground beef or a meatball served between two slices of bread. But that's about it. It wasn't a bond. It didn't have the name hamburger in a lot of instances. It was just kind of a sandwich. No one can say for sure exactly when the first properly compacted bun-in-case hamburger appeared. But one of the first steps toward the modern hamburger also happened to be the first step
那时，我们只有一堆松散的、供应类似汉堡物体的场所。这些原始汉堡通常涉及松散的碎牛肉或夹在两片面包之间的肉丸。但仅此而已。它不是一个整体。在很多情况下，它甚至没有“汉堡包”这个名字。它只是一种三明治。没人能确定第一个真正压制成型、面包夹肉的汉堡包究竟是什么时候出现的。但通往现代汉堡包的第一步，恰好也是通往快餐的第一步。
toward fast food. When, as the legend goes, Please be advised that serious sex hemicorpority can neither confirm nor deny the veracity of the next 30 seconds of this audio program. One day, sometime between 1912 and 1916, a self-described Nairdouelle and Fry Cook named J. Walter Anderson was repairing some meatballs at a diner in Wichita, Kansas when, according to David Hogan, he was frying these meatballs and he got frustrated
正如传说所言，请注意，Serious Sex Hemicorpority既不能证实也不能否认这段音频节目接下来30秒内容的真实性。有一天，在1912年到1916年之间的某个时候，一个自称是游手好闲者兼煎锅厨师的J·沃尔特·安德森正在堪萨斯州威奇托的一家餐馆准备一些肉丸，据大卫·霍根说，他在煎这些肉丸时感到很沮丧，
and took the spatula and just slammed it down and made it into a patty. David is a history professor at Heidelberg University, an author of a book about White Castle. He put it between two halves of a bun, and now we have the food that we're most familiar with. But people liked it. Now, whether Walt Anderson was truly the first
于是拿起铲子用力一拍，把它拍成了一块肉饼。大卫是海德堡大学的历史学教授，也是一本关于白色城堡的书的作者。他把它放在两半面包之间，现在我们有了我们最熟悉的食物。但人们喜欢它。现在，沃尔特·安德森是否真的是第一个
to create a contemporary hamburger is not really what matters. What matters, and the part of the story for which we do not need to issue a disclaimer, is what happened next. Building on his success, Walt opened his first burger place in 1916, outfitting an old shoe repair stand with three stools
创造出现代汉堡包的人，这并不重要。重要的是，也是我们不需要发布免责声明的那部分故事，是接下来发生的事情。在成功的基础上，沃尔特于1916年开了他的第一家汉堡店，把一个旧的修鞋摊改造成了只有三个凳子的店，
selling burgers for five cents apiece. The stand's official slogan was buy him by the sack. David Hogan's book, by the way, is called sellin buy him by the sack. David Hogan's book, by the way, is called Selenum by the Sack. Eventually, Walt's burgers would be nicknamed sliders. And contrary to popular belief, sliders are not just tiny burgers. They're specifically burgers cooked with raw onions
以每个五美分的价格出售汉堡。该摊位的官方口号是“按袋买”。顺便说一下，大卫·霍根的书叫《按袋买》。最终，沃尔特的汉堡被昵称为“滑块”（sliders）。与普遍的看法相反，滑块不仅仅是小汉堡。它们是专门用生洋葱烹制的汉堡，
because that's how Walt made his. As it turns out, Wichita was the perfect place to set America on its burger journey. In the early 1900s, immigration from Europe and Latin America, urban migration from farms, and the Kansas oil boom brought in thousands of laborers, all looking for a fast, cheap meal. And these were people who were on their breaks
因为沃尔特就是这么做的。事实证明，威奇托是开启美国汉堡之旅的完美地点。20世纪初，来自欧洲和拉丁美洲的移民、来自农场的城市迁移以及堪萨斯州的石油繁荣带来了成千上万的劳工，他们都在寻找一顿快速、便宜的饭菜。这些人是在休息时间，
or on their way to the factory or taking lunch or leaving and they wanted something that was quick and savory and hearty and cheap and that is exactly what these sliders provided. By 1920, Walt Anderson had multiple stands in Wichita, but it wasn't yet a fast food restaurant chain in the way we would understand it. Because there was still a big obstacle preventing burgers from really taking off. Most Americans didn't trust ground beef. Thanks in large part to a book that is so famous, so important, and so influential that
或者在去工厂的路上，或者在吃午饭或下班时，他们想要一些快速、美味、饱腹且便宜的东西，而这正是这些滑块所提供的。到1920年，沃尔特·安德森在威奇托拥有了多家摊位，但它还不是我们所理解的那种快餐连锁店。因为当时还有一个巨大的障碍阻碍了汉堡的真正流行。大多数美国人不信任碎牛肉。这在很大程度上要归功于一本书，它如此出名、如此重要且如此有影响力，以至于
I'm actually a little shocked to realize that it has never once been mentioned in the course of 569 episodes of 99% invisible. Journalist Upton Sinclair's bestselling novel, The Jungle, was meant to raise the alarm of the unsanitary and appalling working conditions at meat processing plants. But it had an unintended side effect. And everybody who read it or heard about it read instead that, oh my god, eating meat is bad. Here's just one passage.
我真的很震惊地发现，在《99%隐形》的569集节目中，它竟然从未被提及过。记者厄普顿·辛克莱的畅销小说《屠场》（The Jungle）旨在引起人们对肉类加工厂不卫生和令人震惊的工作条件的警觉。但它产生了一个意想不到的副作用。每个读过它或听说过它的人反而读到的是：天哪，吃肉是不好的。这里仅摘录一段。
There would be meat stored in great piles in rooms, and the water from leaky roofs would drip over it, and thousands of rats would race about on it. It was too dark in these storage places to see well, but a man could run his hand over these piles of meat and sweep off handfuls of the dried dung of rats. Oh my God. So vice to say the book was impactful enough that over a decade later, many meat products couldn't shake the stink, especially ground meat. But what ground meat really was and everybody knew is meat that had essentially
肉堆在房间里的大堆里，漏水的屋顶上的水滴在上面，成千上万的老鼠在上面奔跑。这些储藏室太黑了，看不清楚，但一个人可以用手摸过这些肉堆，扫下一把把干掉的老鼠粪便。天哪。可以说，这本书的影响力很大，以至于十多年后，许多肉制品都无法摆脱这种恶臭，尤其是碎肉。但每个人都知道，碎肉实际上是本质上
gone bad was ground up and fused with chemicals, literally preservatives, and it would be marketable for another week or so. Ground meat was for the poor. For the better off, eating at one of Walt Anderson's burger stands would have been embarrassing. Walt told the local newspaper that children would routinely order a half a dozen burgers to carry out.
已经变质的肉，被绞碎并与化学物质（实际上是防腐剂）混合，这样就可以再卖上一周左右。碎肉是给穷人吃的。对于富裕阶层来说，在沃尔特·安德森的汉堡摊吃饭会很尴尬。沃尔特告诉当地报纸，孩子们经常会点半打汉堡带走。
Then he'd watch as they would run around the corner to a fancy car where their mothers were waiting. Too ashamed, he presumed, to come into Walt's dinky little place themselves. If he wanted the business to grow, Walt needed a partner, specifically a salesman. Billy Ingram is the ultimate 1920s booster, you know, just hustling nonstop to sell you something.
然后他会看着他们跑到拐角处的一辆豪华轿车旁，他们的母亲正在那里等着。他推测，他们太羞于自己走进沃尔特那个破旧的小店了。如果他想让生意发展壮大，沃尔特需要一个合伙人，特别是一个推销员。比利·英格拉姆是20世纪20年代的终极推销员，你知道的，就是不停地忙碌着向你推销东西。
Edgar Waldo Ingram, who went by Billy, was a wish-a-taw insurance and real estate broker. And in 1921, he partnered up with Walt to help sell the public on hamburgers. Even though, at the time, everyone warned Billy to stay away. But I told him he should keep his name alive in insurance business because he soon would find out that he was making a big mistake fooling around with hamburgers. This is one of Billy's old business associates. But it didn't work out that way. It definitely not. Because when Billy Ingram took a look at the market for burgers, he saw something that disturbed his businessman's beating heart.
埃德加·沃尔多·英格拉姆（大家都叫他比利）是威奇托的一名保险和房地产经纪人。1921年，他与沃尔特合作，帮助向公众推销汉堡包。尽管当时每个人都警告比利离这事远点。但我告诉他，他应该在保险业保持自己的名声，因为他很快就会发现，他因为摆弄汉堡包而犯了一个大错。这是比利的一位老商业伙伴说的。但事情并没有那样发展。绝对没有。因为当比利·英格拉姆审视汉堡市场时，他看到了让他那颗商人的心感到不安的东西。
Now, there was no competition in the beginning. This is from an interview with Billy years later. This may seem strange to you, but when I went to Omaha, there were no hamburger stands. And when I went to Kansas City, there were no hamburger stands. And when I went to Kansas City, there were no hamburger stands. When I went to St. Louis, there were no hamburger stands in St. Louis. And when I came to Columbus, there were no hamburger stands in Columbus. In this glorious vacuum, Billy said about convincing Americans to buy burgers by turning Walt's stands into a special kind of restaurant, the likes of which didn't yet exist.
起初根本没有竞争。这是比利多年后接受采访时说的。这看起来可能很奇怪，但当我去奥马哈时，那里没有汉堡摊。当我去堪萨斯城时，那里没有汉堡摊。当我去圣路易斯时，圣路易斯没有汉堡摊。当我来到哥伦布时，哥伦布没有汉堡摊。在这一片空白中，比利开始通过将沃尔特的摊位变成一种当时还不存在的特殊餐厅，来说服美国人购买汉堡。
Waltz was well aware of the stigma attached to ground beef, so he already had fresh beef delivered twice a day and even ground the meat in front of customers. But with the addition of Billy on the team, these initiatives were taken to new, slightly neurotic heights. He said, we have to have the best product, the healthiest product, in the most cleanly surroundings that we could possibly have. In 1921, Billy and Walt debuted a new concept with a very scientific sounding name, the
沃尔特很清楚碎牛肉带来的污名，所以他已经每天两次运送新鲜牛肉，甚至在顾客面前绞肉。但随着比利的加入，这些举措被提升到了新的、略带神经质的高度。他说，我们必须拥有最好的产品、最健康的产品，以及我们所能拥有的最清洁的环境。1921年，比利和沃尔特推出了一个新概念，名字听起来非常科学：
White Castle System of Eating Houses. White to signify purity and castle to signify strength and permanence. And system to signify a system of eating houses. What White Castle did was absolutely unique. I'm sure there are other versions of automats and small scale diners that really served food quickly indoors. But White Castle had a whole system that made it stand out in its efficiency and
“白色城堡饮食系统”（White Castle System of Eating Houses）。“白色”象征纯洁，“城堡”象征力量和永恒，“系统”象征饮食系统。白色城堡所做的事情是绝对独特的。我相信还有其他版本的自动售货机和小型餐馆确实能在室内快速提供食物。但白色城堡拥有一整套使其在效率上脱颖而出的系统，
really replicated the experience of dining in a way that a lot of other restaurants that had multiple locations didn't really do. That consistency started with the castles themselves. Every restaurant would soon be made out of white porcelain-enabled steel, making the exterior extra shiny and easy to clean. There was a lot of character in these White Castle buildings. They actually looked like castles. They had this kind of aura and stained glass turreted aesthetic that I thought, looking at it,
并且以一种许多拥有多家分店的其他餐厅没有做到的方式，真正复制了用餐体验。这种一致性始于城堡本身。每家餐厅很快都将由白色瓷釉钢制成，使外观格外闪亮且易于清洁。这些白色城堡建筑非常有特色。它们看起来确实像城堡。它们有一种光环和彩色玻璃塔楼的美感，我看着它时想，
why wouldn't you want to eat there? It looks like a lot of fun. Inside, the restaurants all had the same layout, a grill, a counter and five stools. And everything was scrubbed daily. So it sparkled the checkered tile, the woodwork, the utensils. Every restaurant was open concept. So you could watch the cook prepare your burger on a visibly clean grill in front
为什么你不想在那里吃饭呢？看起来很有趣。在内部，餐厅都有相同的布局：一个烤架、一个柜台和五个凳子。而且一切每天都被擦洗。所以它闪闪发光：格子瓷砖、木制品、餐具。每家餐厅都是开放式概念。所以你可以看着厨师在面前一个明显干净的烤架上准备你的汉堡。
of you. And from the very beginning, Billy Angriam said, we want our employees to be extremely positive. We want them to be customer friendly. Billy insisted that employees all wear clean white shirts, pants and aprons. Hair was to be covered by a white paper cap. Fingernails were to be kept neat and clean. And elaborate jewelry and wristwatches were strictly prohibited. The menu featured just a handful of items, coffee, Coca-Cola, pie, and hamburgers, made
从一开始，比利·英格拉姆就说，我们希望我们的员工非常积极。我们希望他们对顾客友好。比利坚持要求员工都穿干净的白色衬衫、裤子和围裙。头发要用白色纸帽遮住。指甲要保持整洁干净。严禁佩戴精致的首饰和手表。菜单上只有少数几样东西：咖啡、可口可乐、派和汉堡包，全部由
exclusively of beef shoulder meat. The smaller the menu, the faster and more reliably the items on it could be made. Likewise, everything about the patties, the square shape, and the five holes which were added later, were designed to promote faster cooking and seemingly instantaneous service every time. The funny thing is today, if we had the exact same experience everywhere we go, we think of it as kind of weird and dystopian, right? But there is a beauty in going to a place where you know what the experience is going
牛肉肩肉制成。菜单越小，制作速度就越快，质量也越可靠。同样，关于肉饼的一切——方形形状和后来添加的五个孔——都是为了促进更快的烹饪和每次看似即时的服务。有趣的是，今天如果我们去任何地方都有完全相同的体验，我们会觉得这有点奇怪和反乌托邦，对吧？但去一个你知道体验会是什么样的地方，有一种美感。
to be like. You know how much the food is going to cost, you know exactly what it's going to taste like, you know what the store generally is going to look like. This was also the time when Americans were becoming more invested in national products than locally produced ones. White Castle appealed to the same customers buying off the rack clothing from Sears Roboc and shopping for Kellogg's cornflakes and Campbell's soup. Uniformity and affordability was the point. I think there was something about what Billy and Grim was selling with the hamburger
你知道食物要花多少钱，你知道它尝起来到底是什么味道，你知道店面大概会是什么样子。这也是美国人开始比本地产品更热衷于全国性产品的时候。白色城堡吸引了那些从西尔斯百货购买成衣、购买家乐氏玉米片和坎贝尔汤的同一批顾客。统一性和可负担性才是重点。我认为比利·英格拉姆用汉堡包推销的东西有一种特质，
that made it seem modern, that made it seem like he has this proto assembly line of people creating all these burgers while, you know, a few hundred miles north, the assembly lines of Detroit are churning out Model T's. White Castle also made its restaurants accessible, strategically building near factories and later college campuses. And during a time when African Americans couldn't travel safely around the country or freely enter most restaurants, David Hogan says Billy Ingram didn't discriminate. He was going to take anybody's dollar. You know, we're in the case of this, anybody's nickel.
让它看起来很现代，让他看起来像是拥有这种原始的流水线，人们在制作所有这些汉堡，而你知道，在几百英里外，底特律的流水线正在生产T型车。白色城堡还使其餐厅易于接近，战略性地建在工厂附近，后来又建在大学校园附近。在非裔美国人无法在全国安全旅行或自由进入大多数餐厅的时代，大卫·霍根说比利·英格拉姆没有歧视。他要赚任何人的钱。你知道，在这个案例中，是任何人的五分钱。
Meanwhile, in its zeal to introduce hamburgers to the middle class, the company developed some slightly bizarre but effective marketing strategies. The company commissioned a study at the University of Minnesota, where a medical student ate nothing but White Castle hamburgers and water for 13 weeks. At the end of the experiment, a food scientist came to the conclusion that a normal, healthy child could subsist off a totally White Castle diet and be perfectly fine. Kind of like the documentary, Super Size Me, except, you know, the opposite. The combination of predictability, cleanliness, and good old fashioned false advertising was
与此同时，为了向中产阶级推广汉堡包，该公司制定了一些略显怪异但有效的营销策略。该公司委托明尼苏达大学进行了一项研究，一名医学生在13周内只吃白色城堡汉堡和水。实验结束时，一位食品科学家得出的结论是，一个正常的健康儿童完全可以靠白色城堡的饮食生存，并且身体状况良好。有点像纪录片《超码的我》（Super Size Me），只不过，你知道，是反过来的。可预测性、清洁度和老派虚假广告的结合是
a winning formula. By the early 1930s, White Castle and, along with it, hamburgers were considered so mainstream and trendy that they had even become the favorite meal of beloved cartoon characters. There's nothing in the world that can compare with a hamburger juicy and rare. It was a craze, it literally was a craze. It was like everybody just thought that this new product was so incredible. Throughout the 1920s and 30s, the White Castle Burger Empire expanded out from Wichita rapidly. In that interview with Billy from later on, he lists off the locations. First, Laredo, then Omaha, Kansas City, St. Louis.
一个制胜法宝。到20世纪30年代初，白色城堡以及随之而来的汉堡包被认为非常主流和时髦，甚至成为了深受喜爱的卡通人物的最爱。世界上没有什么能比得上多汁且半熟的汉堡包。这是一种狂热，确实是一种狂热。就像每个人都认为这个新产品太不可思议了。在整个20世纪20年代和30年代，白色城堡汉堡帝国从威奇托迅速扩张。在后来对比利的采访中，他列举了这些地点。首先是拉雷多，然后是奥马哈、堪萨斯城、圣路易斯。
In Minneapolis, Chicago, Detroit, Indianapolis, Columbus, Cincinnati, New York, and New Jersey. We now have 84 in operation. But White Castle would eventually encounter the problem suffered by every truly great, innovative groundbreaking company. People in cities across America said, okay, there's something about this White Castle.
在明尼阿波利斯、芝加哥、底特律、印第安纳波利斯、哥伦布、辛辛那提、纽约和新泽西。我们现在有84家在运营。但白色城堡最终会遇到每一家真正伟大、创新、开创性的公司所遭受的问题。美国各地的城市里的人们说，好吧，这个白色城堡有点东西。
We're not sure what it is. Let's just copy the whole damn thing. Let's copy the name almost. Let's copy the architecture. Let's copy the burger. Let's copy the delivery system. Let's copy the architecture. Let's copy the burger. Let's copy the delivery system. Let's copy everything. Cupid Hamburg, people on top. Makes you wanna go food but it's not. Cupid. Kids just naturally love Crystal hamburgers because the flavors steamed right into the buns. Before long, you could find White Hut, White Palace, White Tower, Red Tower, Blue Tower,
我们不确定是什么。让我们把这整个该死的东西复制下来。让我们把名字也复制得差不多。让我们复制建筑。让我们复制汉堡。让我们复制配送系统。让我们复制建筑。让我们复制汉堡。让我们复制配送系统。让我们复制一切。丘比特汉堡，上面有人。让你想去吃，但那不是。丘比特。孩子们天生就喜欢水晶汉堡，因为味道直接蒸进了面包里。没过多久，你就能找到白色小屋、白色宫殿、白色塔楼、红色塔楼、蓝色塔楼、
Little Tavern, Little Crowns, Little Castle. That's Castle with a K. Have you ever had one of those wonderful days when everything seems to turn into a tasty donut or a meal of tasty castle burgers? The quality of these copycat operations was often questionable. But since many of the White Castle imitators were housed in white buildings or featured castle architecture like turrets, they appeared extremely similar. Some places didn't even try and come up with a new name. They just straight up called themselves White Castle.
小酒馆、小皇冠、小城堡。那是用K开头的城堡。你有没有过那种美妙的日子，一切似乎都变成了美味的甜甜圈或一顿美味的城堡汉堡？这些山寨店的质量往往令人怀疑。但由于许多白色城堡的模仿者都设在白色建筑里，或者以塔楼等城堡建筑为特色，它们看起来非常相似。有些地方甚至懒得想一个新名字。他们直接把自己叫作白色城堡。
It's trademark infringement, obviously. A company is only as good as its name. You know, when that name gets diluted, it's a threat to their existence. White Castle ended up suing one of the biggest imitators and winning a large payout. But ultimately, it was a game of legal whack-a-mole. It was impossible to go after everyone.
这显然是商标侵权。一家公司的好坏取决于它的名字。你知道，当那个名字被稀释时，这对他们的生存是一种威胁。白色城堡最终起诉了最大的模仿者之一并赢得了巨额赔偿。但归根结底，这是一场法律上的“打地鼠”游戏。去起诉每个人是不可能的。
But even if they could, the company would still face a dilemma. Because the thing that White Castle pioneered, the unique dining experience Walt and Billy started selling back in 1921, it was becoming commonplace. In a sense, there was nothing unique for White Castle to sell that wasn't also offered by its competitors.
但即使他们能做到，公司仍然会面临困境。因为白色城堡开创的东西，沃尔特和比利早在1921年就开始销售的独特用餐体验，正在变得司空见惯。从某种意义上说，白色城堡没有什么独特的卖点是竞争对手不提供的。
And there was one imitator who would do more than just compete with White Castle. Instead, it would essentially replace it by becoming nearly synonymous with fast food itself. Get yourself ready for a trip through McDonald's land. McDonald's was founded in San Bernardino, California by brothers Richard and Maurice McDonald in 1940. That's 20 years after White Castle. And at first, just like the other copycats, it took so much from White Castle.
而且有一个模仿者做的不仅仅是与白色城堡竞争。相反，它通过变得几乎与快餐本身同义，从本质上取代了它。准备好踏上麦当劳之旅吧。麦当劳由理查德和莫里斯·麦当劳兄弟于1940年在加利福尼亚州圣贝纳迪诺创立。那是在白色城堡之后20年。起初，就像其他模仿者一样，它从白色城堡那里借鉴了很多。
Diligent levels of cleanliness, a limited menu. But first, just like the other copycats, it took so much from White Castle. Diligent levels of cleanliness, a limited menu. And if you find an old picture of the very first McDonald's, it has a slogan that says Buy and Buy the Bag on the Marquis. And that's a direct rip off of White Castle. But McDonald's had a crucial advantage that all the other White Castle imitators didn't have. It had Ray Kroc. Kroc was the businessman who took the company national in 1955.
勤奋的清洁水平，有限的菜单。但起初，就像其他模仿者一样，它从白色城堡那里借鉴了很多。勤奋的清洁水平，有限的菜单。如果你找到一张第一家麦当劳的老照片，它的招牌上写着“按袋买”。那是直接抄袭白色城堡的。但麦当劳有一个其他白色城堡模仿者所没有的关键优势。它有雷·克洛克。克洛克是1955年将公司推向全国的商人。
Ray Kroc, bless his heart, just learned somehow to do it bigger and ultimately, I guess you could argue better. Take location for starters. White Castle placed its restaurants near factories, downtowns, and colleges. But McDonald's came of age during the building of the interstate and the rise of the suburb. So, Crock placed his restaurants
雷·克洛克，上帝保佑他，只是学会了如何把它做得更大，最终，我想你可以说做得更好。以选址为例。白色城堡把餐厅设在工厂、市中心和大学附近。但麦当劳是在州际公路建设和郊区兴起期间成长起来的。所以，克洛克把他的餐厅
on increasingly busy highways. And that was something that Ray Crock and a lot of his operators and a lot of his executives helped pioneer was a system to basically flood the zone of American road sides with McDonald's. McDonald's wasn't just a place for someone on foot to grab food on their lunch break. It was for anyone in a car on their way to anywhere.
放在了日益繁忙的高速公路上。这是雷·克洛克和他的许多经营者以及许多高管帮助开创的系统，基本上是用麦当劳淹没美国路边。麦当劳不仅仅是给步行的人在午休时吃东西的地方。它是给任何开车去任何地方的人准备的。
But it was also able to expand much faster than White Castle because it was willing to do something that White Castle refused to do. It franchised. Billy Ingram, bless his heart, was way too much of a control freak to do that. The man who wanted every customer to have the exact same perfect experience wasn't about to relinquish any control. But even if it resulted in the occasional limp fry, franchising allowed McDonald's to grow to 1,000 locations in just over 12 years. Faced with the restaurant's sheer ubiquity,
但它之所以能比白色城堡扩张得快得多，是因为它愿意做白色城堡拒绝做的事情。它搞了特许经营。比利·英格拉姆，上帝保佑他，是个控制狂，做不到这一点。那个希望每个顾客都有完全相同完美体验的人，绝不会放弃任何控制权。但即使偶尔会导致薯条变软，特许经营也让麦当劳在短短12年内增长到了1000家分店。面对餐厅的绝对普及，
it was easy for the public to just assume that McDonald's did it all first. And Kroc didn't disabuse them. To believe the stories of Ray Kroc, he invented fast food. And of course, that is essentially the message that people get today, is that McDonald's was the revolutionary factor in the fast food industry.
公众很容易认为麦当劳是第一个做这一切的。而克洛克并没有纠正他们。相信雷·克洛克的故事，他发明了快餐。当然，这本质上是今天人们得到的信息，即麦当劳是快餐业的革命性因素。
Today, there are more than 40,000 McDonald's worldwide. Meanwhile, there are fewer than 400 White Castles, mostly in the New York area and the Midwest, just a blip by fast food standards. To understand just how small White Castles geographical and cultural footprint is nowadays, look no further than Wichita, the city where the company was founded.
今天，全球有超过40000家麦当劳。与此同时，白色城堡不到400家，主要集中在纽约地区和中西部，按快餐标准来看只是沧海一粟。要了解白色城堡如今的地理和文化足迹有多小，看看威奇托就知道了，这是该公司成立的城市。
White Castle left Wichita in 1938. Now the nearest one is over 300 miles away. I recently went to Wichita to see the first ever White Castle location, literally on Main Street. The original building is long gone. In its place is this large bank. For many years I was told, people would stop in and ask the tellers about the history but when I arrived the bank was boarded up. Eventually Denise Sherman let me into the bank. She's the executive director for the Kansas African-American Museum who now owns the building. This is the actual
白色城堡于1938年离开威奇托。现在最近的一家在300多英里外。我最近去了威奇托，想看看第一家白色城堡的位置，就在主街上。原来的建筑早已不复存在。取而代之的是这家大银行。多年来我被告知，人们会停下来询问柜员关于这段历史的情况，但当我到达时，银行已经被木板封住了。最终丹妮丝·谢尔曼让我进了银行。她是堪萨斯非裔美国人博物馆的执行馆长，该博物馆现在拥有这栋建筑。这是实际的
White Castle plaque. Okay it says site is the actual White Castle plaque. Okay, it says, site of the original White Castle opened March 10th, 1921. It's got a photo here. She showed me how hidden inside the empty building, next to discarded desks, another furniture was an ode to White Castle bolted to the wall. But once we were there,
白色城堡牌匾。好吧，它说，地点是实际的白色城堡牌匾。好吧，它说，1921年3月10日开业的原始白色城堡所在地。这里有一张照片。她向我展示了隐藏在空荡荡的建筑里，在废弃的桌子和其他家具旁边，墙上钉着一个对白色城堡的颂歌。但一旦我们到了那里，
Denise didn't have a lot to say about it. So when did you find out that this was a former White Castle? I knew long time ago. Did you grow up here? Do you have any thoughts on the White Castle history here? The only thought is that it's a shame we don't have one here, but we will honor that and still keep that plaque there. I also don't have to keep asking you questions about White Castle if you don't have anything.
丹妮丝对此并没有太多可说的。那么你是什么时候发现这是一个前白色城堡的？我很久以前就知道了。你是在这里长大的吗？你对这里的白色城堡历史有什么看法吗？唯一的想法是，我们这里没有一家真是太可惜了，但我们会尊重这一点，并继续保留那块牌匾。如果没什么可说的，我也不必一直问你关于白色城堡的问题。
I don't know if I can add anything else to it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's just one of those things. Now, you might think that Denise is an outlier, that Wichita is surely lousy with Wichitans who love to boast about how they invented fast food. But no. While in Wichita, I tried to gauge the public's civic appreciation of White Castle and its
我不知道我还能补充什么。是啊，是啊，是啊。这只是其中之一。现在，你可能认为丹妮丝是个例外，威奇托肯定到处都是喜欢吹嘘他们发明了快餐的威奇托人。但并没有。在威奇托时，我试图衡量公众对白色城堡及其
contribution to fast food history. And although I did find a small handful of fans, mostly the situation was pretty bleak. What do you think of as the first burger chain that you can think of in America? If you had to guess, what's the first burger chain that comes to mind? McDonald's. McDonald's? Do you think there's a fan base for a White Castle here? No, probably not.
对快餐历史贡献的公民赞赏。虽然我确实找到了一小撮粉丝，但大多数情况相当惨淡。你认为你能想到的美国第一家汉堡连锁店是什么？如果你必须猜的话，你脑海中浮现的第一家汉堡连锁店是什么？麦当劳。麦当劳？你认为这里有白色城堡的粉丝群吗？不，可能没有。
Probably not. It's not here anymore. Yeah. I don't like oniony burgers anyways, so I'm not a huge White Castle fan, so that's fine with me. Now, if you've spent any time in the Midwest, this all might seem a little strange, because
可能没有。它不在这里了。是啊。反正我不喜欢洋葱味的汉堡，所以我不是白色城堡的忠实粉丝，所以这对我来说没关系。现在，如果你在中西部待过一段时间，这一切可能看起来有点奇怪，因为
there is nothing the residents of a Midwestern town love more than finding something, anything to brag about. And Wichita is no exception. They just don't brag about White Castle. And there is at least one big reason for this. This is the Pizza Hut Museum. This is the actual original building. Sam Morris is director of staff development and special initiatives at
中西部城镇的居民最喜欢做的事情就是找到一些东西，任何东西来吹嘘。威奇托也不例外。他们只是不吹嘘白色城堡。这至少有一个很大的原因。这是必胜客博物馆。这是实际的原始建筑。萨姆·莫里斯是威奇托州立大学员工发展和特别倡议的主任，
Wichita State University, where, yes, there is a museum dedicated to Pizza Hut. Pizza Hut was started in Wichita in 1958, and while it's not technically the first American pizza chain, it predates all the most famous ones today. Little Caesars, Domino's, Papa John's. Today it has more than 19,000 restaurants worldwide. That's 50 times as large as White Castle.
在那里，是的，有一个专门纪念必胜客的博物馆。必胜客于1958年在威奇托创立，虽然它在技术上不是美国第一家披萨连锁店，但它早于今天所有最著名的连锁店。小凯撒、达美乐、棒约翰。今天它在全球拥有超过19000家餐厅。那是白色城堡的50倍大。
There's various different memorabilia in here. The original cash registers around the corner here. They've got this pair of sweet sneakers. I think they only got 50 made, but what they were supposed to do is you'd click the the tongue and he would order you a pizza. Wait what? Yeah. So pretty ridiculous, but there's all kinds of those types of things. So there's a Pizza Hut Barbie? Let's go see that. There is a Pizza Hut Ken as well, but he's right now in storage. During the tour, I was honestly kind of pissed. Why wasn't the original White Castle this well preserved?
这里有各种不同的纪念品。角落里是原来的收银机。他们有一双很酷的运动鞋。我想他们只做了50双，但它们的作用是让你点击鞋舌，它就会为你点一份披萨。等等，什么？是啊。所以很荒谬，但有各种各样这类东西。所以有一个必胜客芭比娃娃？我们去看看吧。还有一个必胜客肯尼，但他现在在仓库里。参观期间，我老实说有点生气。为什么最初的白色城堡没有保存得这么好？
Where was its fancy museum? Where was its Kendall? But I couldn't be too angry because even if it is a semi-obscure cultural punchline, the truth is that today, White Castle is not struggling. Its definition of success is just a bit different than most of its competitors. White Castle is still family-owned, but it's no longer trying to pitch itself as the definitive fast food chain. Instead, it's found something else to sell. You know, our vision as a family-owned business is to feed the souls of craver generations everywhere.
它那高档的博物馆在哪里？它的肯尼在哪里？但我不能太生气，因为即使它是一个半隐秘的文化梗，事实是今天白色城堡并没有挣扎。它对成功的定义只是与大多数竞争对手略有不同。白色城堡仍然是家族企业，但它不再试图将自己定位为决定性的快餐连锁店。相反，它找到了其他东西来销售。你知道，我们作为家族企业的愿景是喂养各地渴望一代人的灵魂。
Jamie Richardson is an executive at White Castle Headquarters in Columbus, Ohio. He is married to a fourth generation Ingram, and he leaves no room for confusion about the company's current strategy. I'm vice president of marketing for restaurants and retail, but really my unofficial title is Keeper the Crave. Over the years, the company has patiently developed a cult following. People who will go to any length to get their hands on a white castle slider. The fact that you can't always find one nearby now actually works to their advantage. It's kind of like the fast food equivalent of an outlet mall. Once you're finally there, the whole point is to go nuts and consume as many of those
杰米·理查森是位于俄亥俄州哥伦布市的白色城堡总部的高管。他娶了一位第四代英格拉姆家族成员，他对公司的当前战略没有任何困惑。我是餐厅和零售营销副总裁，但实际上我的非正式头衔是“渴望守护者”。多年来，该公司耐心地培养了一批狂热的追随者。那些愿意不惜一切代价买到白色城堡滑块的人。你不能总是在附近找到一家店的事实实际上对他们有利。这有点像快餐界的奥特莱斯购物中心。一旦你终于到了那里，重点就是疯狂地消费尽可能多的那些
tiny square sliders as possible. Something, as Jamie explained, they make sure is always easy to do. palette, maybe someday. That's $6,982 if you're interested. Please call ahead. But yeah, it keeps it fun. We don't take ourselves too seriously. This approach has earned White Castle an extremely loyal fan base. When White Castle opened up a new location in Orlando, Florida in 2020, customers camped out overnight and waited in line for six hours. And for those who just can't wait that long, there's also a version of their favorite slider in the frozen food aisle.
小方形滑块。正如杰米所解释的那样，他们确保这总是很容易做到。调色板，也许有一天。如果你感兴趣的话，那是6982美元。请提前致电。但是的，这很有趣。我们不会把自己看得太严肃。这种方法为白色城堡赢得了极其忠诚的粉丝群。当白色城堡2020年在佛罗里达州奥兰多开设新店时，顾客们彻夜露营，排队等候了六个小时。对于那些等不及那么久的人，冷冻食品区也有他们最喜欢的滑块版本。
White Castle even has an exclusive Cravers Hall of Fame for its most devoted fans. In a small room, behind an undisclosed door, a group of White Castle staff sift through thousands of applications to determine who has what it takes to be inducted into the Cravers Hall of Fame. Wow, I can't believe how many Cravers Hall of Fame applications were get. Applications are evaluated by a panel of judges according to four criteria. Loyalty to the White Castle brand, creative presentation of the story, uniqueness and originality of the content, and extent and magnitude of the author's crave.
白色城堡甚至为最忠实的粉丝设立了一个独家的“渴望者名人堂”。在一个隐藏的门后的小房间里，一群白色城堡的工作人员筛选成千上万份申请，以确定谁有资格入选“渴望者名人堂”。哇，我不敢相信我们收到了这么多渴望者名人堂的申请。申请由评审团根据四个标准进行评估：对白色城堡品牌的忠诚度、故事的创意呈现、内容的独特性和原创性，以及作者渴望的程度和规模。
Inductees are flown to Columbus, Ohio for a formal ceremony at White Castle headquarters, a building which one Hall of Famer described as Willy Wonka-esque. In addition to a giant wooden throne in the lobby, there's also a two-story spiral slide. So there's an emotional connection to these fans that's real. And at the end of the day, we don't try to be like everybody else. All of which helps keep White Castle customers coming back again and again and again. And you can buy them in the grocery store, freeze or frozen. It's it will get you by in a pinch, but it's not the same.
入选者会被飞往俄亥俄州哥伦布市，在白色城堡总部参加正式仪式，一位名人堂成员将这座建筑描述为“威利·旺卡风格”。除了大厅里的一张巨大的木制宝座外，还有一个两层楼的螺旋滑梯。所以这些粉丝之间有一种真实的情感联系。归根结底，我们不试图变得像其他人一样。所有这些都有助于让白色城堡的顾客一次又一次地回来。你可以在杂货店买到它们，冷冻的。它在紧要关头能应付，但味道不一样。
That's Jeremy Brooks, the White Castle superfan who lives in Kansas City, where there are, remember, no White Castles, which is why even though he may not be in the Cravers Hall of Fame, Heena's friends still make the pilgrimage to the nearest White Castle location. In Columbia, Missouri, a four-hour round trip. So is this something that is very premeditated or is it spontaneous? I would say more spontaneous than premeditated. You know, get to like a Friday night and everybody's off at work. It's like, all right, you know,
那是杰里米·布鲁克斯，住在堪萨斯城的白色城堡超级粉丝，那里，记住，没有白色城堡，这就是为什么即使他可能不在渴望者名人堂，他和朋友们仍然会去最近的白色城堡地点朝圣。在密苏里州哥伦比亚市，往返四个小时。那么这是非常预谋的还是自发的？我会说自发多于预谋。你知道，到了周五晚上，大家都下班了。就像，好吧，你知道，
whoever's car has the, you know, the most available room or, you know, get to like a Friday night, everybody's off at work. It's like, all right, you know, whoever's car has the, you know, the most available room or, you know, in best condition, as the case might be with some of us, you know, and just hit the road. Is this in any way inspired by a certain movie? Uh, my, uh, if you want to call it an addiction, call it what it is. My fascination and my, uh, my love for White Castle, uh, exists a long before, long before said movie existed, although that definitely did not hurt things at all. At the end of Harold and Kumar go to White
谁的车有，你知道，最宽敞的空间，或者，你知道，状况最好，就像我们有些人那样，你知道，然后就上路了。这在某种程度上是受某部电影的启发吗？呃，我的，呃，如果你想称之为瘾，那就叫它瘾吧。我对白色城堡的迷恋和我的，呃，我的爱，存在于那部电影存在之前很久很久，尽管那绝对一点也没有坏处。在《猪头逛大街》的结尾，
Castle, there's this moment. Harold and Kumar have spent all night trying to make it to a White Castle location when they finally see one in the distance. And Kuma starts this motivational speech about why his parents immigrated to this country in the first place. They wanted to live in a land that treated them as equals. A land filled with hamburger stands and not just one type of hamburger,
有这样一个时刻。哈罗德和库马尔花了一整晚试图到达一家白色城堡，当他们终于在远处看到一家时。库马尔开始了一段关于他父母当初为什么要移民到这个国家的励志演讲。他们想生活在一个把他们视为平等的土地上。一个充满汉堡摊的土地，不仅仅是一种汉堡，
okay, hundreds of types of different sizes, toppings and condiments. It's incredibly cheesy, but it does take on new meaning. When you realize that what he's referring to, it's White Castle's legacy. This is about the pursuit of happiness. This night is about the American dream. Because even if it doesn't always get the credit it deserves, we live in the world
好吧，数百种不同尺寸、配料和调味品的汉堡。这非常俗气，但它确实有了新的意义。当你意识到他所指的是白色城堡的遗产时。这是关于追求幸福。这个夜晚是关于美国梦的。因为即使它并不总是得到它应得的赞誉，我们生活在那个世界里。
White Castle built. One in which, whether you're on the road or in a new city, you're able to get exactly the thing you're hungry for, and to have it taste just the way you remember, every time. After the break, McKenzie is back to explain why every year thousands of your fellow Americans head to White Castle for Valentine's Day. So we're back with the reporter producer McKenzie Martin. Hey Mackenzie. Hey Roman. So as you know, Valentine's Day is coming up. What are your feelings on this particular holiday? You know, mixed to good. You know, I don't know. Yeah, I get that. Well, I personally, I like the aesthetic and the chocolate-centric aspect of it, but I
White Castle 建立。无论你是在路上还是在一个新的城市，你都能确切地得到你渴望的东西，而且每次吃起来都和你记忆中的味道一模一样。休息之后，麦肯齐将回来解释为什么每年有成千上万的美国同胞在情人节前往 White Castle。所以我们回到了记者兼制片人麦肯齐·马丁身边。嘿，麦肯齐。嘿，罗曼。如你所知，情人节快到了。你对这个特殊的节日有什么感觉？你知道，心情复杂但还不错。你知道，我不知道。是的，我明白。嗯，我个人喜欢它的美学和以巧克力为中心的方面，但我
find being in a restaurant on Valentine's Day just a horrible experience. To the point that I cannot go out, the stakes are just way too high. You've got these expensive pre-feaks, menus, everyone's supposed to be having this super romantic night. It's just a lot of pressure. And that is why Roman, when I found out that White Castle has a unique kind of Valentine's Day tradition, I was immediately hooked. Yeah.
发现情人节在餐馆里吃饭简直是一场可怕的经历。以至于我无法出门，赌注实在太高了。你有这些昂贵的预设菜单，每个人都应该度过一个超级浪漫的夜晚。这压力太大了。这就是为什么罗曼，当我发现 White Castle 有一种独特的情人节传统时，我立刻就被吸引住了。是的。
You have to be intrigued by that. So tell me more. So in essence, every year on Valentine's Day only, all participating White Castle locations in the country transform into a fine dining establishment. But it's not stuffy because it's still White Castle locations in the country transform into a fine dining establishment. But it's not stuffy because it's still White Castle. So, um, it's just suddenly it has table service, it's got menus, white tablecloths, candlelight, roses. And they have been doing this for a long time, since 1991.
你一定对此很感兴趣。所以多告诉我一些。本质上，每年只有在情人节那天，全国所有参与活动的 White Castle 分店都会变身为一家高级餐厅。但它并不沉闷，因为它仍然是 White Castle。所以，嗯，它突然有了餐桌服务，有了菜单、白色桌布、烛光、玫瑰。他们已经这样做很长时间了，从 1991 年开始。
So, we're coming up on nearly 35 years. And I first heard about this tradition from Adam Chandler our Fast Food expert from the episode. I presume you remember him. Of course, of course So I don't think I made this super clear in the episode, but I cannot stress enough How fascinated Adam is by fast food. This is my dog Arby after the roast beef place buy fast food. This is my dog, Arby, after the roast beef place. Arby? Yeah.
所以，我们快要接近 35 年了。我第一次听说这个传统是从我们的快餐专家亚当·钱德勒那里听说的，他在那一集中出现过。我想你还记得他。当然，当然。所以我不认为我在那一集中说得非常清楚，但我怎么强调都不为过亚当对快餐有多着迷。这是我的狗 Arby，以那家烤牛肉店命名的。Arby？是的。
Oh my gosh, I love that you're talking to a name Arby. Arby, come on. Sit. Nine years ago, Valentine's Day was approaching, much like it is now, and Adam had just started dating someone, which is kind of an awkward thing. You know, Valentine's Day felt like it was a lot of pressure to put on the early moments of a relationship.
天哪，我喜欢你对着一只叫 Arby 的狗说话。Arby，过来。坐下。九年前，情人节临近，就像现在一样，亚当刚开始和某人约会，这有点尴尬。你知道，情人节感觉给一段关系的初期阶段带来了很大的压力。
So he had heard about this Valentine's Day tradition at White Castle, but he'd never gone and he figured, this is what I'll do, but he decided to keep it a surprise. And I said, we're comfortable clothes, which is a red flag immediately in a romantic date situation. Oh, I, I don't know. a red flag immediately in a romantic date situation. Oh, I don't know. Any sort of surprises make me nervous. Romantic style surprises make me extremely nervous. It really, so I'm very worried about this.
所以他听说过 White Castle 的这个情人节传统，但他从来没去过，他想，这就是我要做的，但他决定把它作为一个惊喜。我说，穿舒适的衣服，这在浪漫约会的情况下立刻就是一个危险信号。哦，我，我不知道。任何形式的惊喜都会让我紧张。浪漫风格的惊喜让我极其紧张。真的，所以我对此非常担心。
I also hate surprises. And it's also worth pointing out that this woman is a food writer. Oh my God. So like she went to culinary school. So it was maybe a bit of a gamble for Adam to take her to a fast food restaurant in the first place, let alone for this extremely romantic occasion. But his rationale was that it was almost like a litmus test.
我也讨厌惊喜。而且值得指出的是，这个女人是一位美食作家。天哪。所以她可能上过烹饪学校。所以亚当带她去一家快餐店可能有点冒险，更不用说是在这个极其浪漫的场合了。但他的理由是，这几乎就像一个试金石。
So the idea that I would be able to take a date to a White Castle and have a good time seemed like For the right person it excellent experience and for the wrong person maybe it would tell me something about my relationship I'll grant him that it will tell you something about your relationship Depending on how that goes, but I still am not sure if it's the best idea to do this on Valentine's Day So what happened? Well, they get there to this white castle in Brooklyn, and it is no longer a normal white castle. It is now for one night of the year, declaring itself the love castle.
所以，我能带约会对象去 White Castle 并度过一段美好时光的想法似乎是……对于合适的人来说，这是一种极好的体验，而对于错误的人来说，也许它会告诉我一些关于我关系的事情。我承认这一点，它会告诉你一些关于你关系的事情，取决于进展如何，但我仍然不确定在情人节做这件事是否是最好的主意。那么发生了什么？好吧，他们到了布鲁克林的这家 White Castle，它不再是一家普通的 White Castle 了。现在，在一年中的这一晚，它宣布自己是爱情城堡。
Oh my God. Okay. Love castle. It's perfect. Okay. Keep going. So just picture it. The whole restaurant is decked out with like paper hearts and red streamers and paper background with kisses on it.
天哪。好的。爱情城堡。太完美了。好的。继续。所以想象一下。整个餐厅装饰着纸心、红色飘带和带有吻痕的纸背景。
There's this romantic playlist coming out of the speakers, the candles on the tables. I mentioned earlier I'll be at like LED candles, but still and the hostess shows Adam and his date to their reserved table, gives them a menu, which is of course Valentine's Day themed. Okay, tell me more about this because I can't imagine what romantic dishes await them on the White Castle's Valentine's Day menu. I know right? Well, I don't know exactly what they serve that time, but this year the Love Castle will be serving the Love Clutch Collection, which is a White Castle meal for two. Last year they offered a special Sprite Love Castle potion,
扬声器里播放着浪漫的播放列表，桌子上有蜡烛。我之前提到过，我会用 LED 蜡烛，但仍然……女主人带着亚当和他的约会对象来到他们预订的桌子，给了他们一份菜单，当然是情人节主题的。好的，多告诉我一些关于这个的信息，因为我无法想象 White Castle 的情人节菜单上有什么浪漫的菜肴在等着他们。我知道，对吧？嗯，我不知道他们那天具体供应什么，但今年爱情城堡将供应爱情组合系列，这是一份供两人享用的 White Castle 套餐。去年他们提供了一种特别的雪碧爱情城堡药水，
which is like this cherry vanilla version of Sprite. Another year they debuted a strawberry swirl cheesecake on a stick, and that one actually ended up saying on the regular menu, so very classy. And on top of that, they have White Castle Valentine's Day merch too. So we've got a White Castle scented candle, red heart shaped Love Castle sunglasses. And there's also my personal favorite, the Love Castle robe, which is this maroon satin kimono style robe with drawings of Cupid and sliders all over it.
就像这种樱桃香草味的雪碧。又一年，他们推出了草莓漩涡芝士蛋糕棒，那个实际上最终留在了常规菜单上，所以非常高级。最重要的是，他们还有 White Castle 的情人节周边商品。所以我们有 White Castle 香薰蜡烛、红色心形爱情城堡太阳镜。还有我个人最喜欢的，爱情城堡长袍，这是一种栗色缎面和服风格的长袍，上面画满了丘比特和滑块汉堡。
Oh my. Okay. I think I see what they're going for. It's like a little cheesy, a little over the top. And then they just seem to be able to balance it all with a really good sense of humor. That's a good way to put it. And that is why when Adam arrived at the Love Castle with his date and he sees all of this, being the fast food fan that he is, he was immediately charmed by the spectacle. The environment there can't be beat.
天哪。好的。我想我明白他们的意图了。这有点俗气，有点夸张。然后他们似乎能够用一种非常好的幽默感来平衡这一切。这是一个很好的说法。这就是为什么当亚当带着他的约会对象来到爱情城堡并看到这一切时，作为一名快餐迷，他立刻被这种奇观所吸引。那里的环境是无与伦比的。
Everyone's having a good time. And it just takes all the expectations away from what is normally, I think, an over-pressured, over-hyped, unnecessarily stressful event. Well, you know, the fast food writer with a dog named Arby likes it. No doubt about that. But like, you know, what fast food writer with a dog named Arby likes it. I had no doubt about that.
每个人都玩得很开心。它消除了通常情况下，我认为是一个压力过大、炒作过度、不必要地紧张的事件的所有期望。嗯，你知道，那个养着一只叫 Arby 的狗的快餐作家喜欢它。毫无疑问。
But like, you know, what did his date think? She also liked it. Okay. Thank God. Okay. In fact, it was such a success that his date is actually now his fiance. And they have had White Castle for Valentine's Day every year since. Oh, that is the cutest thing I've ever heard.
但是，你知道，他的约会对象怎么想？她也喜欢它。好的。谢天谢地。好的。事实上，它非常成功，以至于他的约会对象现在实际上成了他的未婚妻。从那以后，他们每年情人节都会去 White Castle。哦，那是我听过的最可爱的事情。
That's amazing. And since this episode comes out the day before Valentine's Day, and they are, of course, doing it again this year, tomorrow will be their 10th time. Oh, that's so sweet. It'll be their 10th White Castle anniversary. Well, Mazel tov to them. It's a very beautiful thing. And it turns out that a lot of other people have also made this an annual tradition.
太棒了。而且由于这一集是在情人节前一天播出的，他们当然今年又会这样做，明天将是他们的第 10 次。哦，太甜了。这将是他们的第 10 个 White Castle 周年纪念日。嗯，祝贺他们。这是一件非常美好的事情。事实证明，许多其他人也把这变成了一个年度传统。
One story that Adam told me that stuck out the most was this group of five women in Minnesota who are all widows, and they go every year to reminisce about their late husbands. And I think that that again kind of speaks to what it means to have places that are accessible and affordable and democratic that are welcoming to anyone on a day like Valentine's Day, which can be isolating and lonely. There's not a lot of that left, I think, in American life. There aren't a lot of meeting places and third places where you see all kind of swaths of humanity uniting, especially over something as intimate as a meal.
亚当告诉我的一个故事最让我印象深刻，那是明尼苏达州的一群女性，她们都是寡妇，她们每年都去那里缅怀她们已故的丈夫。我认为这再次说明了拥有无障碍、负担得起且民主的地方意味着什么，这些地方在情人节这样的一天欢迎任何人，因为这一天可能会让人感到孤立和孤独。我认为，在美国生活中，这样的地方已经不多了。没有多少聚会场所和第三空间可以看到各种各样的人群团结在一起，尤其是在像吃饭这样私密的事情上。
You know, Adam's making a really good point here because I think it's pretty easy to look at the extreme commodification of food in this way and feel like this mass produced food is made for mass produced people who have, you know, mass produced feelings and it's all the same. And, you know, the food is treated like a product, your kind of treated like a product. However, I have been in a car with a bunch of kids in the back chanting
你知道，亚当在这里说得很有道理，因为我认为很容易以这种方式看待食物的极端商品化，并觉得这种大规模生产的食物是为大规模生产的人制作的，他们有，你知道，大规模生产的感情，而且一切都一样。而且，你知道，食物被当作产品对待，你也被当作产品对待。然而，我曾经和一群孩子坐在车里，他们在后座高喊
nuggets, nuggets, nuggets. And it's like a joyful experience that they can all have this thing and we can have fun with it and enjoy it. And it's just kind of great. And fast food can be both those things at once. Yeah, I feel like fast food is kind of all of the worst things and all of the best things about America packed into one 10 sack of sliders. I still think 10 sliders, it seems like too much. It's really not. Now, I do need to point out that White Castle isn't the only fast food establishment that
鸡块，鸡块，鸡块。这是一种快乐的体验，他们都可以拥有这个东西，我们可以从中获得乐趣并享受它。这真是太棒了。快餐可以同时是这两者。是的，我觉得快餐就像是美国所有最糟糕的事情和所有最好的事情打包成一袋 10 个滑块汉堡。我仍然认为 10 个滑块汉堡，看起来太多了。真的不是。现在，我确实需要指出，White Castle 并不是唯一一家
pulls out extra stops for Valentine's Day. Maybe you've seen this around as well, Roman. There are reports of individual McDonald's locations doing something like this. I always wanted to take a leaf out of White Castle's playbook, but these chains have had mixed results. Like, notoriously, pizza places like Papa John's and Pizza Hut tried to sell heart-shaped pizzas back in 2017 and got a lot of social media hate when customers received horribly misfigured pizzas or ones that only became heart-shaped because they showed up with a slice missing. So this is one area where Adam says White Castle continues to dominate.
在情人节做出额外努力的快餐店。也许你在其他地方也见过这种情况，罗曼。有报道称个别的麦当劳分店也在做类似的事情。我一直想从 White Castle 的剧本中借鉴一二，但这些连锁店的结果喜忧参半。比如，众所周知，像棒约翰和必胜客这样的披萨店在 2017 年尝试销售心形披萨，当顾客收到形状极其扭曲的披萨，或者只是因为少了一片才变成心形的披萨时，在社交媒体上遭到了很多仇恨。所以这是亚当说 White Castle 继续占据主导地位的一个领域。
Well, that makes sense to me. Like if you're going to do Valentine's Day, associated with a fast food restaurant, White Castle sounds like the safest bet and also kind of the perfect amount of like, kitchen style that they seem to have perfected over the decades. Totally. But Adam did warn me that Valentine's Day is now in under 24 hours, so if you haven't planned ahead, don't think you can just waltz into a White Castle tomorrow night and expect to be seated.
嗯，这对我来说很有道理。如果你打算过情人节，并与一家快餐店联系在一起，White Castle 听起来是最安全的选择，而且也是他们几十年来似乎已经完善的那种厨房风格的完美程度。完全正确。但亚当确实警告我，情人节现在不到 24 小时了，所以如果你没有提前计划，不要以为你明天晚上可以随便走进一家 White Castle 并期望有座位。
You have to book early. I book like three or four weeks in advance sometimes ahead of time because it sells out. The times sell out. I'm not joking. This is a hot ticket. So, have you booked your reserve seats for Valentine's Day this year? Definitely not because you may remember when I started reporting this episode, I had never actually been to a White Castle
你必须提前预订。我有时会提前三四个星期预订，因为它会卖光。时间段会卖光。我不是在开玩笑。这是一张热门票。那么，你预订了今年情人节的座位了吗？绝对没有，因为你可能记得当我开始报道这一集时，我从来没有去过 White Castle
at all. That's right. But like since then, have you gone? I have. I'm happy to report that I recently rectified this. When I finished all the reporting for this episode, I had to see what the fuss was about. So this past November, I finally had my first non-frozen, in-person, White Castle experience. I'm going to get two 1921 sliders.
根本没去过。没错。但从那以后，你去过吗？我去过。我很高兴地报告，我最近纠正了这一点。当我完成这一集的所有报道时，我必须看看大家在吵什么。所以去年 11 月，我终于有了我的第一次非冷冻、亲身的 White Castle 体验。我要买两个 1921 滑块汉堡。
Yeah. And I'm also going to get the original cheese slider. Okay, so what was the verdict? Do you love it? Do you hate it? Are you now a Craver? Are you potentially going to be in the Craver Hall of Fame? It was awesome. Like, I get it now. I get it. That's great.
是的。我还要买原味芝士滑块汉堡。好的，那么结论是什么？你喜欢它吗？你讨厌它吗？你现在是一个渴望者吗？你有可能进入渴望者名人堂吗？太棒了。就像，我现在明白了。我明白了。那太好了。
I think these are way better in real life. I think the bun's way better. The pickle's really good too. Well, this is awesome. Well, I'm so glad that you could do this whole story and then find in the end that you actually enjoyed the burger because that would be such a disaster if you didn't. Thank you so much for bringing this story. It was just great.
我认为这些在现实生活中要好得多。我认为面包好多了。酸黄瓜也很好。嗯，这太棒了。嗯，我很高兴你能做完整个故事，最后发现你实际上很喜欢这个汉堡，因为如果你不喜欢，那将是一场灾难。非常感谢你带来这个故事。这真是太棒了。
It was great working with you too. Thanks Roman. 99% of visible was reported this week by Mackenzie Martin produced by Jacob Moulton on Medina and edited by Joe Rosenberg. Mixed and sound designed by Martin Gonzalez, Music by Swan Real, with additional music by Jenny Conley, Nate Querry, and John Newfeld. Fact-checking by Graham Hayesha.
和你一起工作也很棒。谢谢罗曼。本周的 99% 可见度由麦肯齐·马丁报道，雅各布·莫尔顿和奥纳·梅迪纳制作，乔·罗森伯格编辑。马丁·冈萨雷斯负责混音和声音设计，音乐由 Swan Real 提供，珍妮·康利、内特·奎里和约翰·纽菲尔德提供额外音乐。事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙完成。
Cathy too is our executive producer. Kurt Colested is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Baruppe, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lodge Mad Dawn, Gabriela Gladney, Kelly Prime, Nina Pottuck, Sarah Bake, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his belogo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
凯西·图是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科莱斯特德是数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁佩、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·莱、洛奇·马德·道恩、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、凯利·普莱姆、尼娜·波图克、莎拉·贝克和我，罗曼·马斯。99% 可见度的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作的。
We are part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. A different version of the story first aired on the KCUR studios podcast of people's history of Kansas City and was lovingly edited by Gabe Rosenberg and Suzanne Hogan. People's history has got a ton of fascinating stories all from Kansas City's peculiar corner of the Midwest.
我们是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦。在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心，非常漂亮。这个故事的另一个版本首先在 KCUR 工作室的播客“堪萨斯城人民历史”中播出，并由盖布·罗森伯格和苏珊·霍根精心编辑。人民历史有很多迷人的故事，都来自堪萨斯城中西部独特的角落。
We highly recommend that you check it out. Adam Chandler's book about America's fast food kingdom is called Drive Through Dreams and for even more about White Castle, you can check out Selenum by the Sack by Dave Hogan. Find them wherever you find your books. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our very own Discord server. We have a link to that on our website as well as every past episode of 99pion at 99pion.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们强烈建议你去看看。亚当·钱德勒关于美国快餐王国的书叫《得来速梦想》，关于 White Castle 的更多信息，你可以看看戴夫·霍根的《按袋销售》。在你能找到书的任何地方找到它们。你也可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器上找到我们。我们在我们的网站上有一个链接，以及 99pion 的每一集往期节目，网址是 99pion.org。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。